this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
and breaking news right now authorities
say someone was murdered in the central
valley yeah this happened not too long
ago and not too far from mccarran
airport that's where we find sasha loft
is live with the latest
denise and brian we're on spencer street
which is right by maryland parkway and
tropicana you can see the road is
completely blocked off here as police
are well in the way of this
investigation now officers were told
responded to a report of a shooting
earlier tonight that's when they found
one victim here again on spencer street
that person was taken to the hospital
where they later died again this is
being investigated as a homicide
investigation is underway
no word on how long this road will be
closed but of course this will continue
for a while longer so definitely avoid
the area against spencer street right by
tropicana and maryland parkway we'll of
course stay worse of course rather stay
with eight news now for the very latest
on air and online as we get more
information on this reporting live
tonight sasha loftis 8 news now